running Bender The Craze driver drove by
and he said Chris what are you doing now
he said the twins want to meet you then
I'd have a drink with them I'd go down
and see him
and they were always always really
polite and I remember they said to me
Chris we got a problem
won the lads it was very very well known
God Rest his soul a good bloke
uh
is in jail
and his message is having it with
somebody on Romford Market
um yeah what's the problem
well it's got to be sorted
he wants him up but he doesn't want him
dead
so okay
it's going to be done
and I went to walk away and Ronnie Craig
said to me Chris he said
I've got a sign for here and he gave me
a watch
and it was solid gold Waltham which said
bought a watch as a Piccadilly